welcome to camp et thank you it's
gorgeous I love your animal our
beautiful grass did you ever go to camp
uh no i didn't know that's a lie i went
to piano camp Oh what when I was young
that's a thing yes so for a week you
just play classical piano and that's
what I did I love it yeah that's when my
parents thought I was gonna be a smart
kid over you and you went to piano can I
was like 13 yeah so it's like the
perfect age to hate yourself yeah VidCon
is like summer camp how is it like
rubbing elbows with your the people in
your community it's really great first
vid con like four years ago for me was
like I'm mostly in my hotel room I don't
know anyone here i'm a stranger to
everything but now it's like I've seen
the same people year after year and now
we're good buddies your buddies honestly
after that first party it's like nobody
has any shame after that exactly have
you been here for four years like what
do I need to know to survive this crazy
weekend oh uh you probably need to know
where the lounges are yes and each
lounge is like a different theme like
it's looks like pink and chic or like oh
this is little grunge or like the
animated Willy Wonka lounge yeah but
it's like really good to recharge their
and plus they all have they have things
to eat and drink VidCon has become a
huge thing and like et is here it was
very bizarre for me right um because I
come from the internet it's like a
strange it's a strange thing to eat too
much the internet now I internet go et s
et online